ja lacht nur aber wie beneiden you
unsere bild schlagzeile sorgte auf der
insel heute für stolz fröhliche
gesichter ein bisschen häme und große
wellen selbst die daily mail berichtet
mit stolzgeschwellter brust davon auf
twitter wird schon von einem deutschen
user medizinisches asyl beantragt denn
die briten kriegen es hin mit dem impfen
schon dreimal mehr impfungen wurden
gespritzt als in deutschland
im streber großbritannien wundert sogar
die briten selbst die hose gehen das
deutsche im pflaster lockt am ende soll
in großbritannien im juni seien die
urlaubsbuchungen sind um 400 prozent
nach oben geschnellt einige lassen sich
aber auch noch etwas zeit
gartenarbeit herrlich wir dürfen nicht
mal ins gartencenter sie beneiden you
und hören uns auch leider ganz gerne an
was ihr bald wieder alles machen dürft
[Musik]
super toll liebe briten wie beneiden you
und schauen mit traurigen augen richtung
sommer wenn ihr ganz in ruhe ihre
handtücher ausbreiten könnt und euch
wieder einen fiesen sonnenbrand holt
mehr nachrichten und breaking news nur
bei bild schaut euch hier das nächste
video an und vergiss nicht zu abonnieren